but has your family started giving you
parenting advice since you're now
uh yeah you know um well because the
funny thing is i have 20 nieces and
nephews
so christmas might be hell it's crazy
yes but it's fun you know like i i've
seen a lot of my nieces and nephews
through different stages of their lives
yeah
um and but you know obviously it's
entirely different when it's yours so
yeah but i've i've i've got somewhat of
an experience except for the diaper
changing part but
yeah um that's easy people like it's not
hard
it's easy you get used to it really fast
yeah
and then you it gets it actually gets
you become gross and you don't know it
you're like oh gosh i'm out of a and
then you just you
you do things that you would never
thought you would do and you're like
it's fine
um so do you have any parenting advice
for him
selma you know there is everybody tells
you
it goes so fast yeah and there are
moments where you go
that's not true this going quite slow
you know
i want her to talk to me i want to
communicate
and it's actually so true because
all of a sudden it just goes so fast and
you can never get it back
so really cherish every moment
uh re record write things about it are
you having a boy or a girl
i'm having a girl i wanted a girl oh
yeah
what an exciting time i love the
decorating the room i loved all of it
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever